Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
What?
Oh, I don't know.
What is happening?
I'm live right now. I'm live. I'm live too.
What are we even doing?
Oh God, what a disaster.
What?
Blah blah blah blah blah.
What? We're live! We're live in me!
She's like, fuck this stream. I'm gonna go make some tea.
What a disaster.
Oh my God.
What?
Power washer, if you haven't played the entire campaign, it doesn't allow you to have six persons in your lobby.
And I'm the only one with a finished save file and it was too late to like ship all the like code and information to like send on on your stream.
And so basically she be rescued. She be was like, right, I'll set this one out. You guys just do it.
And we're like, no, we can't do it. The whole point of this is that we're all together in this.
So then we're like, right, who's got Gmod, right? I don't have it, right? Who's got Raph, right? I don't have it, right? Who's got this game? I don't have it.
I was trying my best.
She was like going through the list. She was flicking them pages like next page, next page, next game, next game.
Okay, that won't work.
Okay, sure.
All right, we'll do Jack Fox. And then wait, that requires us to screen record this court.
I'm like, we can't have that. We see every just things in the discord.
We don't even have a HR department. So we can't share.
So then, um, garlic phone, which I've never played before is coming in clutch right now.
Um, Amy's currently making a cup of tea at Mercy.
Um, is just getting a room set up for her.
Um, because she accidentally nuked her vault of her, the collapse room.
It was an accident.
Oh my God.
This couldn't have gone any worse.
I think that's like pretty on character.
Yeah.
If someone could insert that meme and put all of her hairs on it and be like, oh, aren't, aren't VTubers cute when they're almost, or a little, almost, a little.
That's all I'm going to say. Well, you guys can finish the sentence after that.
But that was, I can't.
No, I'm kidding.
I was like, okay, I'm going to be honest. When they, when the harem told me they were called harem, I read it as harem.
And I was like, that makes no sense for she be character design.
I was like, what?
I have a harem of so many people that are my little, you know, play things and clients and they're my harem and that's hair.
Which is a rabbit.
But it's not a rabbit.
Hair and rabbit are different.
But you know what I mean?
It's a pun.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And they're also called harlots.
The individuals are harlots or harlots.
Wait, hold on.
I thought you said hairless.
They're hairless.
Some of them aren't.
I can tell you that.
Check it.
Marcy, you could.
Do you still have that thumbnail, Marcy?
Are we good now?
I got it.
Almost.
Almost, I mean.
I'm back with tea.
Marcy, if you still have that thumbnail, if you just throw up the stream.
Is she going to throw up on stream?
No.
The audience beaming.
Yeah.
It should default to that.
If you just change to the thumbnail and pick our take four.
I'm literally telling herself the stream was just streaming.
I'm sorry.
I cannot right now.
My goodness gracious.
Why are they too loud?
Yeah.
How's the volume?
It's my volume.
Okay.
Can you hear everyone else?
Who said the harlots are waxed in my chat?
The harlots are waxed.
I need them to be clean and proper.
I'm good.
I see it.
Okay.
That's good.
No.
I'm not going to.
Okay.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're saying.
I'm sorry.
I do not know.
Well, you know what?
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
On man?
It's broadcast on the OBS?
That was.
I'm doing so bad.
They called.
We have the column.
Thank you for the 10 members.
Yeah, there is for my non-monetized
No, she Vian is there are monetized. Oh my god. I'm muted. I was
muted the entire time. Oh my god. I can hear you.
I don't know what is happening.
Right
This is a fever dream guys. This is real. We're all in bed
I guess I should change my stuff now
Why do we need to change wait?
No, you don't have to change anything as long as the game's on stream
You can change it after stream no one gives a shit what the streams called as long as we're online right now
Okay
Okay, mommy. I'm just doing it cuz we're all there's like every I'm sitting here
The girl's running around like everything's on fire, and I'm like it'll be fine. We're good
We're gonna play some Garthik phone. We're gonna have a great time
They think the world is gonna end don't forget to like and subscribe on this stream if you're enjoying your experience as a viewer
Oh
Smash that bell to get notifications of life
Yeah, like with alcohol or something. Yeah, I am
Yeah
Love smashing
She just says smashing
I'm sorry for the mess
Okay
We a vealor have done the holistic approach where none of us will mute so
It just as a reminder all donations
Memberships or super chats will be addressed at the end of the stream when it's not an absolute cluster buck of all six of us together
But yes, the whole premise of the power washer was I was gonna do a gag and be like oh
Vealor isn't doing so well. We might go bust so everyone put a bikini on and get clean in well that I
Window now, so instead we're playing Garthik phone. I've never played it personally
she be
Suggested it and I her word is law. So
I'm taking over the company I'm the shadow CEO
Okay, do you guys want to start you ready?
Right I sentence I know cheating the guy is so chat. Don't fucking cheat. Don't fucking do it. I swear to God beat your ass
I
Planks don't give out way until it's
This is our secret
Oh wait
Wait, I don't actually know what that is so let me
Oh
My god
Oh, I can't see don't cheat. This is so bad. Oh, no
Wait, can I make my pen smile smaller? She
Know what's happening
Oh the top right corner is the indicator of the shading, okay, I'm an artist
An artist. Oh, yeah, wait, all you can fucking draw about me. That's that you're all done
We need to witness them hold on
The fuck am I doing what is
I
Should whip out my
Better with a mouse
Would you I'm done
You
These are items
100% wood wood, why not?
We need to put the chat logs in quick
These are the chat. Oh good answer
Why are you ain't ready? Hey, you guys aren't ready for mine
And we need to some which detail was Americans always have like an eagle
To describe this
There we go
What do you think
Oh
My god, I don't know what he looks like
Hey, she be sent so far away
Oh
Right, I don't know what
Looks like oh no, I had to look it up. I'm just guessing. I'm just going for it
Right, what I look like
Wait, I don't look like that
Oh
How do you draw a hegeo
I don't know how to draw it
But ginger in it and there you go, that's me. I don't know what
This is awful, I'm sorry
This is this is I don't know. Let's
Draw some hair
It's too late the phone run
Oh
That is very nice, thank you, I'm glad you agree chat my little leaflings are saying I'm a true artist
Here's not orange
Oh
What does that even say my loss may I out eat may I oh meow
Which one of you speak Spanish
Oh
Do we even have oh, I look like oh wait, I can't even draw the fucking toilet
This is terrible one mouse
I love the shit
Pits is armpits we're like we're grabbing on to the ground for dear life in this one
No
Cuz cuz none of you guys know like some English phrases and or some like joking phrases
So I can already like I'm what I'm hearing is that a lot of you guys are misinterpreting whatever in and it's very funny
It's going all over his back. It's not looking good
How do you draw an angry mouse like a yeah, oh there we go
And then
Sweet this is amazing. What does the Walmart logo look like what oh?
Man if your your armpits has become sentience
One more
Oh wait
No, it makes it better it makes it worse
Perfect I think that works out
Radiation I can't wait to see everyone's
There's gonna be no voiceover and then we'll do the beginning from the end. Yeah, okay, okay
So, hey, let's see I see so I said I see with Nigel's thornberries face saying smashing
Oh
Go ahead
Actually worked out
Why would you say I'm such a fat cock
So strong is I'm sorry
Actual cheese
I
Like that pull I like that pull I never stinky Pete's which is both was his feet but like
And then she drew
Oh
She's screaming so loud
I mean your job me your job is a poo. So when your poo hits your prostate on the way out it feels
Wait, is she giving a blowjob
Oh
My god
Boy
Oh
Okay, it's a wanky face. I was like, what is Mia was I was like
Okay, this makes sense this makes sense of what on earth we were drawing
Because I guess the check out and like that's items on the shelves. I worked really hard
I see understood me
The devil I love the details
It's going everywhere
Because that's all I see about when I'd like to see American means we're like all the toilets
The toilet gap is so big you can literally look at people's eyes
Oh, no, we have them closed because you know, it's a private time and you're very vulnerable taken a big job
So, yeah, it's actually closed everywhere else in the planet
Yeah, I had people peeking at me in high school through the stalls
Oh, no, did a bird DC is there a check? Yeah
Is there a DC check you in the lobby? Do you need reload that lobby?
And it's gonna do it on its own usually not I've gone gone
The link should be in the discord. Don't show your fucking screen on the desk
Naughty photos we just send to each other
It's mostly memes I mean to be fair with a chair
He knew the worst
Role-playing is the girls will not know so I was like, this is what if he would do
AC would do
Discord is so chaotic. Okay, real though
I'm an also I did snort out my tea it like went down the wrong hole and went on my own
Wow mercy I hear snort and tea
Oh
Heartbeat right now every time she talks
See
Azura could do a really good Jennifer Coolidge impression
Oh
Oh my god
Azura the base
Click that link in the general this
Oh
Here's me you're making
So it just goes
It's company loading it says
Oh
Well you guys see the discord if I open it okay, you guys can't see it. No
I would close the window capture in the in the OBS just in case
Yes, you're gonna turn off. Just are we restarting a new lobby a big new lobby?
Oh, yeah, let me know invite to this lobby a bit of all
I only see one of you
Okay, which one you play which one so you got normal which we just did knock off keep yourself focused
Try to replicate the drawings while the clock gets faster
Animation create an animation in a collaborative way icebreaker play with a sentence ask questions and have fun with others drawings
Exquisite co-ops create surrealist characters connected by the top of the drawings. Don't know what that means
Hold on my dear
Burt friends have a good time with that compliment comp complete the sketch
Start with basic lines and see other players interpretations master piece
Create a piece of art play in a single term with no time limit. I think story would be funny
Write an area of using only the previous sentences. Oh, yes. Okay. Okay story story story. Okay story. Okay. Yeah, let's let's try story
Start writing
Wait, do I have to write a full story or just a sentence just a sentence? Okay, okay
Oh
Do you like write the whole story or no, no, you can you hope you have really limited characters
There's time
Oh my god, I wanted to write more. I wanted to write only write one sentence
Shit
We are not be in the caca
Oh, they're gonna know this is me spelling it cuz I didn't use a
Yeah, I'm sending it. I'm not even spell checking
Oh, oh the sentence is so small like I want to
I couldn't write until what
Okay, let's see
It's funny because
I can't think of anything
The bleeding hearts and the hero I'll get to see this unfold and we're all just taping like
Wait
So
You fuck you watch fucking big bang theory wait, that's nice about Paris
I
Need more layers I need more like
Song lyrics they jerk so hard mother fuckers want to find
And the Jerry so hard mother fuckers won't pay
wait
This agency
We can't just this agent I spelled it wrong, but that's the point
They don't give you enough to write like
Okay
So how about everybody reads their own story like yeah, of course the first line. Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh, okay
I go first in a galaxy far far away. There was a goat with big titties
She had so much milkers and started raining milk
Azara then went on to make an empire bane milk daily
It was so successful
Kingdoms
Stronger than any porn addiction
Also
I
Watches a beach of agency that was lived
The
So they dance the pee pee dance until they could and then finally they peed everywhere on the
Floor the walls the bed the kite
I
Once upon a time there were whores they were the elitist of whores
They all had
More like bang bang your mom last night keep my mom out of your
Oh
I
Know you guys know why
Is there a do you have a make filter on I can never hear you
There's no filter on
Your steel series
I
Can't wait for the board if they survive me and these words
Another another another new one new one new one
Please please no more shit
No promises
Oh
All the actions are mystery drawings and sentences are hidden during you can't hear mercy mercy test
Mercy test sorry. Sorry. I was muting because I was coughing because I was laughing my side
Okay, mercy test complete do you want to do calm play meant
I
Complete we grow on each other's drawings. We should try that. Okay. I think that would be fun. Yeah
That's some basic lines sketch some basic lines, okay
I
Do like some basic lines like whoo
Okay, boom
Yeah, I'm just gonna draw a bunch of
Castle
Are you joking
Okay, you know exactly what you did and no, I don't have the strength to resist
What?
What I got it. I got it. I can make this I can salvage this
This is the back legs of it and then this is it's huge
There you go only a few more
Uh-huh, yeah, you're so dirty reef lens
Honestly
I'll get the girl to tell you off. If you don't behave that's shocking
You guys don't have innocent eyes
Rude to me
We are my way am I supposed to finish this off. Are we finish it off? I think so cuz it's given us
I'm big
Oh my god, I've just made she
Oh, that's a thing. Oh, no, that looks like
Dang it, let's just do the pencil
Here we go I
Saved it I saved it
They give you a lot more time for the second. Yeah, you're to finish it. You're to finish it. Ah, you need to finish
Okay, I'm fucking stupid. No, I'm I'm
Okay, that makes so am I don't worry
Okay
Let's let's put some nice shading in to make this look extra beautiful Wow
Let's put the beauty of nature. Yeah, it's so beautiful
I saved it
Oh
They pranking me I think this is the best I got
Oh, these are all the shaft
Oh
I really know what I want to do, but I know I shouldn't do it cuz we're on YouTube
This is amazing. Oh
Wait, maybe hold on hold on. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it
Fuck how do I go back? Okay? Oh, fuck. What is
This is so fucking good, let's fucking go
I'm like trying so hard right now. I can't even think of anything to say I'm like trying
Oh my gosh, use your imagination
There you go
I'm so proud of you
Reflings we need to be nice
Let's pray for you
Yeah, it's a water bottle
I
Saved the pair of all sex
No, it just works. I don't know
Senpai, can you do better shut the fuck up? I
Love when you do that
Oh
My god, I just realized
Snippets like fucking girl
From Star Wars. Oh
Wait, no, is it heartbreak on the chair?
I
Was gonna draw a coochie or a woman giving birth, but I'm not I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
I've literally don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now. There we go
Oh my god, I have time
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
And then be like once
Pen pals fuck
Pen pals quick quick quick quick. I'm running out of time
Oh
My god, this is okay
These are like ones
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying I got I got I got
Oh
God refunds refunds how could I forget your
This is the best I got I ain't got none else
Oh
Why do I feel like
This is a really specific reference, I don't know if anyone's gonna get it but there used to be a
Flash game where your guy was on like a snowboard. I love that game. Yeah, someone's literally just drawn that
Literally, this is perfect
Oh
That's it, that's what you're on
So this is Lane Raider. Oh, I thought we're just called
What is bear pencil
I
I thought people were asking me to draw a bear wearing underwear. I was like
Nancy pants
I remember fancy pants
Because he had big old pants that were fancy
Rain up and now we're not the time you know the story. Is he blonder that on me go?
Oh, you know the story
I might make that up
Right hydration check girl, you don't want your voice is dying. Okay
Okay
Pants read oh
He had no hair color, but it's pants for yellow
Let me do that. I don't know. I do something
Needs hip. Yeah, you're right. I don't really know how to do that though
Oh
Yeah
So it's like beer braid braid is pants
Yeah, okay
No, fuck it. Let me know what is the who drew ball sacks everywhere
It's not you she be I only see no, I didn't draw a bullsack
Hold on I got it
Who's whispering I have no idea
What
There is whispering some like evil incantations to it
This is all I see right now, and I'm not even gonna pretend otherwise. It was definitely zero that drew the ball sack a hundred percent
Why does like why do I feel like this is a lie?
No, I didn't draw it. I'm really drawing over it right now
If you guys didn't know as there is ears actually have gold
jewelry on the end of them
Oh
She's pimped out with jewelry, but it's like not a vanity thing
Gifts for her first
bike ride
Right. Is it cheating to erase? Oh, fuck it. Isn't it cute?
So if you didn't know when a woman
When a woman lactates, yeah
Oh my god
It goes through the fabric
Okay, so they'll be like
I know this is
Oh, it's terrible. Get rid of that. I'm doing that. Oh my god. What am I doing with my life?
Now I was trying to talk about lactation, duh
This is yeah, it was right before she sat in chocolate. That was correct milk
What the fuck milk
The best I go
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face and now them some titties made
It's all I can see
I have saved I have single-handedly saved the stream probably
This is supposed to be it the liquid
The liquid
Fine
I started it and I'm gonna finish it. It's me
Okay, fucking mental
I don't know I'm already pooped from this
It's the old it's the old Mac, okay
Okay
I would talk but it takes too much brain power to
Yeah
This is a net
It's a pretty good net
I think I did a great job
Uh
How do you spell squelch squelch, squelch, squelch, squelch
Yeah, yeah, I am
Is it the Amazon? Oh my god
Uh
Is it the reverse amazon position when the girls what are you?
Yeah, like that's definitely
May break it may break it may break
Oh, wait, I need to click them. Wait, let me hydrate
No
Okay, does anybody need to take a quick break before uh, I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm ready. Let's go
Let's do this
Oh
Okay
Yeah, they are for me. Yeah. Oh, that's so good
Sorry, what do you mean? You're a bad artist. That's a very good. That's beautiful. Yeah, that's so cute
He got boner under the blanket and everything
Oh, it is the Arthur view. Let's see it now. Beautiful
Okay, what else could I draw for this?
Okay, okay, okay
Oh
They saved them I lied I lied I didn't save you at all
I was if I don't see a snail
Don't leave Zara. Oh, oh my god
Oh
I love replays. Oh my god, that's so cute
I was like it may break it may break
Okay
Oh
Yeah, that was cute
Literally me that's me
Oh my god, these are so bad. I can't I can't show that
We'll do me and the boys
Oh my god
Why the mono bro
Wait
Wait, I drew this little game. I was like, oh, this is like lane raider
That's creative
That's really cute
That's cute
I told you I told you it was Zara
Llama chuba for gentoo
And then I saw the thing on the right
Oh, that's cute mercy
Oh
You did wait, I was learning how to ride a bike
Oh, that was good
The most innocent
Help
Oh
Oh, okay, hold on. I'll stop it. Why don't we cancel it?
Yeah, it's boring it's boring can I cancel it?
I don't know if you want okay, how do we cancel?
Wait, are we doing this or are we cancelling it?
I don't know
Oh, there's a fucking add
I'm gonna make it another room. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
All right
Where's my just making carry that and you guys can see john snow and sun to start
There's a way to put me back in they still advertise
Wait, so do we have a new room in the same lobby? Do we have a new room? Put me in this?
Yeah, it says one of seven
Wait, what is happening? I don't know what is happening?
Somebody else make a lobby it's not the greatest but we can just play it
Is everybody else make a lobby?
I'm confused. Do we have a new lobby or not?
Somebody else make it because I made a new one. I was trying to make a new one
Right everyone hate the asset hate the game the garlic phone window
Okay, hide it first and then someone make a new one. I can't make it because my connections dog. I'll do it
Okay
See emmy proven what a big girl she is
That was so fucking weird. I'm sorry
So fucking creepy. I'm so sorry. Thank god
Sorry, it's so it's so chaotic
I don't know why there's two of me on screen when I hate up. I hate that
So we are putting in your lobby
Yes, let me just put up a new show. There's a link in the discord. Okay. Okay. Okay
I said it. Okay
understood
Life page
Let me open the link. Oh, there we go. Nice and easy
I've got a picture. Okay
Okay, is everyone here?
I'm here. Yes. I'm in. I'm in here. Yeah, I'm in here. Okay. Which one do you want to play?
I don't know. Uh
Knock off is fun because it's like super
Try to replicate the drawing. Oh the drawing. Oh, yeah. Yeah, do knock off. Do knock off. That looks good. Okay
If you make it pretty drawing and then it becomes hell. Oh, wait, why are we supposed to draw?
Anything
Give us something I'm being put on the spot my mains going blank
Let's do a campfire. Oh, we're getting good. Chibi. We can't see relax. I'll draw
I'm taking off the blindfold. You're fine now
I'll draw chibi
Should we all just like draw somebody
Oh
No, I'm joking. I'm joking. I'm joking. I was like, oh, I'm kind of locked in there. Uh, sorry. Sorry. I've decided to draw one of us
That I've already said out loud. I don't know what to draw
No, I'm like give me an idea
You'll put on the spot
Don't don't put me on the spot. I don't know. I don't even know what to draw
Put me on the G spot. Oh, one of you guys. So I'm gonna choose
On the spot
You want me to draw that?
Oh, this is terrible on a mouse
That one's actually funny
Uh, oh
Can I draw the how much time do we have I'm like, can I draw the whole gang again?
You have quite a bit of time with this one. Okay, hold on
We're gonna draw the whole gang with this. Oh, that's not who the berries look
How the fuck do you draw something sitting down? Oh my god, I'm having a stroke. I'm not the good king. What on earth?
Oh
There's a good
I'm supposed to be a snow fairy
I'm gonna get beaten up by anything after this. Oh my god
Oh my god, what
I want to draw harmony. I want to draw your name
Perfect, I can't draw like this
It has kind of like
He's mixed we need to draw the devilish
Fuck this is hard because like I don't know what to fucking draw
Get creative nerds. Jeez. It's not that
Okay, miss artists
I literally
Emmy comes at Emmy's like, oh, I'm just gonna draw myself casual and it comes out with like this fucking banger of a commission
It probably costs like $500 to do
Oh, yeah, she's like bang that out and I'm like, oh my god
I'm gonna make a vtuber model
Wish I could wish I had a pink a pager durable talent
Speaking of that, so it's heavy a fucking marshmallow. They were like, thank you for not tying down your talents
To the designs that you assigned them and they can be more themselves and I'm like, yeah
Why would I do that?
I was like, I don't know why I feel like it's such a basic things. What the fuck I need drawn out a bleeding heart
Yeah, we're just we're more or so like building upon
I tried the characters rather than I have changing everything literally because um
Oh someone rated the vtuber. They were like the only thing that would have been it better
As if you let them design their models like from the start
I'm like, bro, it took me a fucking year to get here. Like, oh my god. Give me like a fucking
It takes forever to
It is it is not like an overnight rig a vtuber model. Yeah, honestly, right? Who am I?
You can ask him. He knows how to do it. I'm gonna run a lot of work
Oh my god
Yeah, there's only a select few corpos that will let you do that. Oh, literally it takes so long. Oh, shit. Oh, shit
This is rough
Usually ones that have like artists in
Yeah, we don't
If not all of them say first you will have pre
pre-made
So it's not actually standard for the people to choose. Yeah, it's really not you
That's why it's usually they cast for the roles
What the fuck is that star
Oh
Okay, now we have to draw it. Are we ready?
I just I have to be ready for it even if I'm not
It's okay
Just draw it your way and that's the fun part. Yeah, very nice
I've already forgot which position everyone
Oh, this is so bad
Sorry, we flinch honestly, I would talk more but this takes so much brain power to do this
I'm so brain dad like I'm fucking done. I'm like
I'm reading chat. I'm reading everything, but I'm not responding. I'm so sorry because the everyone's
I'm just really in this
That's far too short so
This is why
I don't remember what
Oh
We draw this as fast as we can oh fuck
No, no, no, not like this
Shit, shit, shit. I can't remember what it looked like
Is there supposed to be someone in a pirate boat by the way because I don't think I saw it
That's supposed to be a person in it. I don't know. It's already never already gone
if there's a person
Oh my god
Okay, that's that's easy enough
This is enough
Okay, gotta go fast gotta go fast
Oh my god, I am so sorry
Oh
Okay, okay, okay, okay. We can do this. We can do this
I can do this. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
Fucking guys, we are all panicking
Oh
Okay, this is easy. This is easy easy. This has to be miss mittens. This has to be mittens
Easy easy peasy. Let's fucking go
Let's fucking go man. This looks like shit, but a while
Oh
I mean, that's that's close enough. What if
Oh my god, that was rough enough
That was rough
That's amazing
Oh
I was like, this is mr. Mittens
At least it stayed
So I did a little campfire with all of us together
Let's not surprise me
Oh, we're arguing over a fire say angry face. I can't like I gave him faces
Oh, that's so good. At the end of the day, we're all just
Okay, this is good. This stage this stage
Perfect circle
Oh
She's not in jail. She's at the cage
Wow
One piece I was like
Oh
I was like, why is she shooting her piss?
Okay, that's supposed to be me
You're giving your big balls the best you need to serve us
The piss will revive him
Oh, the piss will revive you
Oh
That was so good, right one more one more
What when have we not done
I don't know
I don't remember all the actions are a mystery drawing and sentences are hitting during the game
Which one is this secret
Secret seems rough. I've never done that one before
All right, I'm sorry. Mr. Okay. We'll try it. We'll try it. All right last room boys last room. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um
Oh, what I can't see what I'm ready
Oh
Huh
Yeah, oh no, wait you run out of freaking words. Oh, bro. I can't erase my sense. I don't know
It just appears. Oh, we can't see what we're drawing
Oh
Okay, I don't know I think
I'm gonna just guess
What it is where it is. Oh god, that's so funny. What the fuck?
Oh, no, no
I'm gonna try to draw. Why is it so hard to draw with the mouse?
Can I can I put backwards does it work like that? I didn't give you his legs
Oh
Yeah, um
I used to somewhere there
Okay
Okay, that's a lot all wrong. No
What
Okay
Oh
Oh, I don't know what else to draw. That's that's exactly what I drew. I think
This is a vain reference. I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
Oh
in
I locked in did I give
Wait, I spelled that wrong. Wait. Did I give them bodies? I don't think I gave them bodies. Oh my god
I don't even know where they are
I'm taking a shot in the dark
What that is going to be interpreted as and will I stop the creative flow?
Do you
No, Amy. Amy's got a hoodie here. Oh sugar. I don't
Fucking I put juice on her
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing anymore. I'm fucking dying
What what is this? What is this?
It's beautiful. What?
Okay, cousin. What is happening? What is this?
Someone had a stroke who drew this one. Hope you're feeling okay. Hope you're doing all right. Make sure you hydrate
Oh, fuck. I didn't have enough time to write it
Uh, man, how do I even draw this?
This is uh
That's the tongue
And then this is literally everyone
This is so difficult. What the fuck am I drawing?
I
I need like a motion swipes as well and a little arrow to indicate
Yeah, there we go. I think I drew it correctly. Well, where is it?
Cute
I need
No, my hair my hair. I can't wait to see the end of this. Yeah, that's
Something else. This is a great. This is gonna be fucking insane
What's going on the ceiling on each row on the ceiling quick? Oh, I think I've dropped something. I don't know boy
Oh, I'm so scared of what these look like
Same
Oh
I was gonna write even being cooked
That's why you're humming Indiana Jones. I was like, where did that come from?
I was trying to write cowboy, but I did
Oh
Hey, did you draw it in white?
And right I used to write as well and orange
Oh
Eraser, that's why you can't see it
That potato is really bad never mind
Oh
You learn number one
Maybe something's not enough to us. Oh my god
Oh
That's how we got there
Are they drew us
Oh
My cheeks hurt
My jaw
Oh
I love this
No, the freedom
Not the premium pass AC at the convention they got the premium pass
Tag yourself, I'm the
Tying in me to the tracks. Oh my god, right
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna endure the girls to anything more because like we're our faces are ready to fall off after that
Is anyone doing a stream?
Is anyone
Are you doing a stream right away?
Right, I'm going to jump out of the call
I
I'm going to jump out of the call and do a little search so then I'll redirect into you as a role. Okay
Oh my god, okay, I'm gonna be starting though
Okay, I might play do you guys want me I might play some call the lamb
So if you if someone does a pop-up stream just tell me I'll talk to that my refunds for a bit
Thank you so so much all members and dolls for this hilarity that ensued after such a miserable start
Such a miserable start to power wash or
Shack myself from laughing so hard
Oh, it's really we already know ac's panties are soaked so
All right, let me sniff
Rather pungent my dear
You have to take attack
Great, I'm gonna jump out of chat. Thank you so much
And we will be doing collabs next week with each other. So look out for that
Uh, and I'll jump out of chat. Thank you so much. Uh my darlings my daughters my girls
I'll talk to you very shortly. Okay. I'm off to the refunds. I love you my daughters
My
They're so cute, right
That was really something
Are you guys still streaming?
I am I am I feel like I lost my ability to stream
I gotta go off. Okay. Let's go off go to just chatting and then right into into azra
I think azra's next right
No, yeah, I'm gonna be
Me and azra are gonna be streaming. She's doing stardew. I'm doing call the lamb
Wait, wait, so so she be and azra are going to stream right now
Yeah, I'm gonna keep streaming. No
I'm gonna I'm probably gonna I'm probably gonna end this one so that the vod is separated
Oh, yeah, that's a good idea. Actually, it's true. I didn't make a new one
Okay
Oh hang up and then I'll go to the uh, la la la just chatting and then I'll send
I'll I'll check if y'all ready. Okay
Later
Okay. Bye. Bye
Bye
Oh
Oh my god
I feel